and then we've got the on-chain cost
basis here which i think is probably uh
driving some of your kind of price
levels uh that you're talking about
earlier so explain what on-chain cost
basis is and then why you're so fixated
on the numbers that you're talking about
with 53 40 et cetera so we're just
looking at the average price of which
investors bought in on chain
um for like technical traders you know
what i would say is the way to think of
this is like a v watt so volume weighted
average price
and so this this price level has been
really important if we zoom out you'll
see this is served as support for the
you know 2017 bull market
once we broke below you know we flipped
bearish and then that we kind of had
these failed underside re-tests the
whole way down into the bottom of the
bear in 2018 once we got back above this
we you know came back off of the lows in
the bottom of the bear
we broke below this about two weeks ago
uh went below 53k and what i said was
until we reclaim this i maintain you
know kind of this cautious stance and i
still do so
that sits right around 53k um that also
aligns with kind of technical this kind
of nice technical level uh as well as
the one trillion dollar market cap
threshold um and so this is this is why
i keep saying 53k 53k i'm sure people
are like tired of hearing that um you
know that that's kind of where i'm
getting that number from so you know
once once we get back above that um i'll
happily you know load on load on btc um
and just to be clear you know i have i
have a you know dca that i'm regularly
designing into i also have a trading
portfolio so when i'm talking about this
i'm talking about my trading portfolio
um you know if we get back above 53 i'd
love to just happily pile back in but
until then i kind of maintained um you
know caution in that sense uh so i would
i would look to either buy the 53k
you know break or i would look to kind
of uh you know buy if we retest that
that wick down being a below call it you
know between 42 to 45k with invalidation
at 40k um so those are kind of the two
areas that i'm kind of looking to do
business if you will
um you know but but you know for the
balls you you want to see 53k get
reclaimed but in terms of like where i
would buy
yeah i would either be you know
reclaiming that that level or you know
looking for some kind of uh you know uh
you know buy below below this you know
uh well you know if we if we swing the
wick you know down to
42 45k um and then invalidation would be
at 40k
got it joe what question you got well
what's going on man good to see you
again um so my question would just be
around like you personally how do you
look at the the more high level macro
stuff right so we got news yesterday
that they're signaling three rate hikes
for 2022 how does this impact your view
from the on-chain side
being like a bitcoin analyst i think it
you know it's definitely something you
need to keep in mind but at the same
time like i'm not gonna sit here and
like pretend that i'm like this expert
macro analyst right and so like i think
it's it's almost difficult enough
already to keep up with the bitcoin
market let alone like predict you know
what's going to go on with macro and so
the way i kind of look at this is like
if if investor behaviors change then
you'll see that through
price and on-chain data
and so those are kind of the two like
true tellers because you know obviously
like
macro included in this like there's a
lot of variables right and so
to kind of just like
get you know the signal of all of that
information you know in in uh in a
concise way you can look at what's the
behavior of the investors on chain and
you know the purest version of that is
just looking at what the price action is
telling you because that's the
aggregated opinion of all market
participants about all information given
right
and so yeah i mean i don't really i
don't really like
like try to read too much into what's
going on with the fed you know i have
people much smarter than me that i
listen to in that regard
um but yeah i mean in terms of like what
people or what the market thinks about
it i just watch what happens you know
with price and and what happens in the
launching data to kind of gauge what
people are making of that because you
know that's like literally telling you
the reaction of people to all the
information at hand so yep gotcha man
thanks john will so my question is
it's not funny my question is around
kind of the having cycles and where you
think we are so we obviously had a
having in 2020 we're gonna have another
one on 2024 but we went up and up in the
spring down in the summer up in the fall
looks like we're kind of consolidating
what people consider a bull market what
are your thoughts around the having in
like the price of bitcoin right now yeah
i don't i mean i think there's a
correlation but i don't really think it
matters to be honest um and the
reasoning is because the having well a
like having the uh kind of the supply
shock if you will that it has on the
market is completely diminished from
like the first one so like you know the
first having in 2013 is pretty
significant given the issuance versus
the amount of circulating supply but at
this point the next having will pretty
much just you know be relevant in terms
of uh you know the the magnitude of it
um and then second of all the the other
reason i'm kind of talking about like
viewing from these four year cycles is
just the type of market participant that
we have um you know i think i think
these are much more sophisticated market
participants um and not to say that we
won't have you know 50 to 80 drawdowns
uh i just i just kind of lean away from
this very clean you know looking you
know four-year logarithmic kind of we
cup up you know have a parabolic blow
off top come back down and accept this
you know
just traditional whenever you look like
logarithmic regression charts for
bitcoin i think i think uh
too many people and this is like my pin
tweet is like too many people have been
trying to you know project the past on
to the future rather than think like
what does the future look like
and so by no means am i saying that
we're gonna go up forever at all i mean
obviously like i've been actually kind
of like standing away from that um but
you know when someone talks about like
what is a super cycle right a super
cycle would be
you know kind of having these rounded
tops and bottoms moving forward uh
without any kind of major you know blah
top so like my invalidation for my idea
here would be if we do have a blow off
time like if we have a blow off top i
would i would very much expect that we
have some kind of you know prolonged
bear market but until we have you know
some kind of parabolic blow-off time i
think we'll continue to kind of see
these these rounded tops and bottoms
moving forward and that's just a
reflection of the type of like market
participant that we have now is it fair
to say the having in 2013 wasn't almost
priced in because it was so significant
on the amount of bitcoin that got cut in
half and then people are starting to
realize that it is a little bit or no
yeah yeah i mean i i think that's the
case back in 2013 um but by now you know
i
if anything it's just like a uh
psychological thing that people say like
oh yeah well whenever this happens this
happens right rather than like the the
amount of supply getting cut in half
actually having like a material effect
on you know the supply demand dynamics
in the market um with that being said
though i don't think that means that you
know as soon as the having happens
people say like oh well every time
there's a having price goes up you know
if if if you think that's the case then
it just gets front ramp right like you
know the type of investors we have now
in the market are really smart so you
know they're just going to say oh well
if this happens every time that there's
a having then we'll just front run that
so you know i i don't really i'm not
like paying too much attention to the
the having moving forward um you know i
just think we're kind of
um
i'm not saying like oh this time is
different per se i just think like we
have a different type of market
participant and so the market structure
is going to change and it won't just be
a repetitive you know four year cycle i
think i just think kind of that's like
intellectually lazy and i think like
that's just you know it would be very
nice for crypto natives because then
they could just you know
buy in the bear and then just sell off
in the bowl and then just chill until
the next you know bulmar you know i i
just don't think that's that's really
going to help that's going to be how it
goes you know i think also like talking
to some people who are um you know
obviously my kids so like i'm not gonna
talk like a bunch of institutions but
talking to people who do
um you know like i i don't think you're
gonna see like capital you know coming
into the space slow down and also you
know it takes time
so like over the last year or so if you
had you know different institutions that
are looking to allocate you know it
takes them you know sometimes like a
year plus or two years plus to you know
be able to
to you know get to the point of making
the decision that they want to start
allocating to being able to actually
allocate especially for some of these
like public companies um they're like
big you know like bureaucratic you know
institutions so you know i just think
like over time you're going to see the
market structure change
in my base case for what that will look
like it's just that we have these
rounded tops and bottoms and then the
invalidation for that is if we do some
kind of like parabolic blow off top